since the leader of Isis was killed yeah
a surprising hero has been thrust into
the national spotlight I'm talking about
the military dog who was instrumental to
that operation get this apparently this
is true the dog's name is Conan now
there's more that is absolutely true but
according to Newsweek magazine check it
out this is real the dog is named after
me that's right the dog was named after
the comedian Conan O'Brien and not the
famed barbarian I heard this any in all
sincerity I just want to say what a huge
honor that is it really that's a huge
honor to be named after this dog that
did something so heroic you know we
couldn't talk about this last week it
took forever a couple days to confirm
the dog's name and was only late last
week that they actually confirmed it and
we heard that the dog was named after me
and I was very honored but we didn't
have a chance to talk about it so Conan
the dog is now scheduled to visit the
White House this week so I just have
pretty much one question where is my
invitation seriously I think I deserve
some recognition here because if you
think about it we're both kind of heroes
I don't know what you're laughing I
don't find this funny at all I mean it
makes sense the dogs named after me so
it's sort of like the dog and I did this
together you know I'm not asking for a
lot I just like to be honored at the
White House alongside the dog I think
that's reasonable I also think that I
should receive lifetime veterans
benefits for myself and for my entire
family
I'm sorry what do you what's horseshit
I'm a hero wait a minute why is that
oh we didn't know you were done barking
sorry no wait a minute
technically I personally did nothing
heroic but I am the hero's name sake so
I deserve some accolades I really do you
say a lot with very few barks okay I
just want to say dog you're being very
mean that's all I'm gonna say
[Music]
you have a very stilted speech pattern
as a dog look you've made your point
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes sir
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you applauding we're all dead
I think they blew up the wrong studio
poor Ellen anyway
[Applause]